i watched an episode of uh anahana again
oh yeah
i kind of thought it was [ __ ] i thought
i've watched all of anahana and i
was i was looking at you to be like
don't you i don't you [ __ ] dare
finish the sentence sir
don't drop the s that's kind of [ __ ] i
watched i watched anihana like three
years ago and i [ __ ] bawled my eyes
out great time
yeah i watched the episode one again i'm
like wow what i stuck with episode
nothing happens in episodes that's why
it's [ __ ] episode one
was by far the worst episode and the
episode of one of anahana of
almost put me off of anahana yeah
because i was like that makes it kind of
[ __ ] right
because i thought when it first started
i thought it was like some lolli fan
service bait because i remember the
scene where
menmos sits on his lap and i'm like oh
here we go [ __ ] here we [ __ ] go
again
i'm just i'm just i was just like huh
another another lolly bait fan service
show and then
and then i think it was like halfway
through episode like or like the end of
episode two or three where i actually
got emotionally invested because
i remember episode one was like pretty
bad do you think if anohana came out
today it would be
given the same level of respect that
it's given
i feel like i don't think it could hold
up i don't think so because at the time
that anahana came out there were very
few shows that
went in that direction right right i
feel like and especially with like how
short the show was like it managed to do
something in 12 episodes that a lot of
anime struggled to do in like 20 players
that's why i feel like it's kind of meh
now if you go watch your back i don't
think okay to be fair
you only watched episode one right yeah
that's like i didn't watch it all again
i watched just episode one again well
then that's probably why you thought it
was [ __ ] because
yeah you watched the worst episode but
after i watched it i was like how the
[ __ ] did i make it to episode two after
i watched this
[ __ ] yeah but that's the same as like
every person who watches like the first
episode of steins gate
and it's like why would i continue to
watch it said one of steingate's good
right
i think i think it was boring i i
remember thinking this patient half the
time i don't [ __ ] remember anything
[Music]
for some reason with anime like i do
why did you start to re-watch it yeah
because uh who was it emily and marichi
told me
she thought it was [ __ ] and i thought i
thought no it's good right it's good
so i went back and rewatched it yeah but
i guarantee emily also only watched
episode one was like it's [ __ ] no she
watched all of it she said oh well
come on defend yourself emily i've
rewatched anahana about like
four times i think four times yeah yeah
i've i've only re-watched it once and i
thought it was bro we would have flying
cars by now people stopped re-watching
this many times are you [ __ ] kidding
me because four times why
because i remember i think anahana was
the
very first anime that got me to cry yeah
because i remember back before before i
watched anahana i was like
stoned stone-faced i i can never cry
during
i'm a real anime and then like i cried
like a [ __ ] the first time i watched
anahana
and like after i watched anahana there
were it was so [ __ ] long before i
could find like
other shows that i could you know bring
a tear to my eye i tried watching clan
ad that just didn't [ __ ] happen like
like
and it's so easy to make me cry though
like i feel like just the right beeps
and boobs will make me cry
right and right you find one good daft
punk scene you're like
i love these boobs yeah so like the
reason i rewatched it so many times was
whenever i like i i whenever i felt like
i just need to i just need a good cry
right now yeah yeah but so i would just
put on anahana just just to like get
just just to get those emotions out that
much to get a cry out
before can you not just like do it on
command
no so if i feel like i need to cry like
you say you feel like you need to cry
right yeah yeah
so if i i need that push i need that i
need to like
listen to that song or watch that anime
i pretty much replicate what that guy
did in the best cry ever video
i was like i basically like just sit
there and i'm like
and then once you get it started it like
goes you know for like 30 seconds
does that feel the same as yeah
dude if i'm in the right mood honestly
yeah like if there's if there's like an
emotional soundtrack to it like i can
get it
because the thing is right it's like
wanking
it's like it's just a different type of
wank right in my mind
like they both feel the exact same when
you've done it
like when you cry it feels like a relief
when you're whacking
have you ever have you ever cry
i don't dare try to to mix
how easy
when you do that cry without a heart did
you not feel like when you stopped
crying you're like
ah no that's that's that's why i would
put it on because before that
i i just couldn't how does that how was
the whole process take to make you cry
though
how many episodes you want to watch when
you start crying i mean okay so so so
skip to them
if we're going beyond just re-watching
the entire thing sometimes i would just
like
if i needed a quick quiet like if i
needed like a [ __ ] if i needed like
steps timestamp if i needed like a five
minute wank or whatever and like a cry
wank
i would just put on the final episode
i'd be like wait wait wait
just say you cry to the ending no no
using them using the same using the same
analogy if i needed that like
quick set like the [ __ ] right
right go right to penetration yeah just
just just straight into tears you you go
you'd grow to like the [ __ ] end of
anahana yeah if i needed like the full
buildup or anything if i had like a
whole day to waste and i
just felt if i just felt emotional the
entire day if i just had a [ __ ] down i
just need to cry it out
i just re-watch anahana and i was about
to say like
i i can't imagine someone being like
[ __ ] i need to cry all right time to
invest six hours into this yeah i i just
put like you say run on or something and
then like i just
start crying man okay i completely i
completely uh
like relate to the if i need to cry then
like a good song will do that to me
instantly
like i know i have like a list
immediately
yeah immediately i'm just like i know if
i put this song on
i know the exact time stamp as to where
the tears will start coming out and
should stop men should cry more
yes yeah yeah i i feel like men should
cry more like once once i discovered
anahana
i was like i i was on a [ __ ] mission
to find
my next anime that i could make chasing
yeah it was it was because i don't know
i've always had like
trouble crying or showing my emotions
like publicly or whatever
for some reason like watching and like
the saddest thing could happen to me
irl right yes i just don't cry yeah i
don't know why like
like for example like i i [ __ ] love
my grandma right yeah and i i
thought this entire time when i you know
when she passed away and i went to her
funeral
that i would shed some tears i for some
reason i just couldn't shed
tears even though i knew i knew i cared
about her like
i loved her as like family and like one
of the person
but that's the thing like like you don't
have to like show that emotion
yeah express it like you know outside to
feel it right yeah but for some reason
watching
uh watching a good scene in an anime or
watching that
that just brings it out that just that
just gets it out for me actually no it
feels like
it feels safe at home right like you
feel like all right i can be vulnerable
right i can i can do this here
can you cry in front of other people
though yeah i'm not watching i can't
when i'm in a movie with someone that
doesn't matter who it is if it's [ __ ]
sad i'll be like are you one of those
people who like watches like something
really emotional on a plane
that you can cry on a plane i can cry on
a plane yeah
i think i have cried like i'm like then
they're like
because i'm definitely one of those
people who like if i watch because i
watch makio on a plane yeah and i
[ __ ]
cry like but i had to like really just
[ __ ] straighten my ass i cannot show
weakness to the person
i think it's a subconscious thing for me
because if there's other people around
like there are sometimes that i want to
cry i want to cry and it just
it just sometimes when there's someone
someone else that i just i just lose
like
for us for a split second i lose the
immersion and then i'm like
ah i gotta build up myself like the
tears yeah you have to build up again i
it's crying is hard for me i don't know
yeah i
value it whenever something does make me
cry which is why
like which is why i really value for
example your name right because that was
the only time i've ever cried in the
cinema with
other people around me um but that was
less because it was sad and more because
it's like
there's just so many emotions right now
this is beautiful
let it out somehow um no
you're gonna say i was on a i was on a
train and uh i was on the
i think yamanote line or something i was
watching a video and it's actually about
like they in japan they have uh like
seminars to make men cry oh yeah yeah
yeah that's all right
yeah and so i was watching this video
about like where they
make basically they they just cry porn
to a bunch of japanese businessmen
and it was kind of like a game show
almost in this video because it was like
this one guy was just refusing to cry
and then right at the final click like
the sixth one was like a [ __ ] tear as
he's like
it's so funny but as they were just so
funny but yeah as they were describing
like this the this woman was describing
what was in the clip she didn't show you
it right but
just her describing it i was [ __ ]
like tearing up on the
like yeah like [ __ ]
so [ __ ] so [ __ ] sad i just do
something like it was something like a
a kid's mom passes away and he's helping
with his dad or something
that's so [ __ ] sad holy [ __ ] i don't
want to go through that
yeah i don't know man it's like i know
there's nothing wrong with like crying
in public yeah
i don't know this is not like full-on
i'm just like shedding tears oh yeah no
no but even like shedding tears like i
have like
i don't know i have some kind of
restriction with it i think it's just a
subconscious mental block
i don't know because i have exactly the
same thing and i wish
i wish i could like bring out my
emotions more easily but
because it takes it it takes me so many
[ __ ] steps to get
to get to that point yeah you know that
that that's why
i don't give a [ __ ] though
it's not about giving a [ __ ] like i
don't i don't give a [ __ ] but there's
i don't know something's something like
give a [ __ ] no i'm like i'm like i'm
like
i'm like in my head i'm like cry cry cry
cry and then something my brain's just
like nah don't do it don't do it
yeah yeah i guess there is like some
it's you know just
mental block that even when you know you
should it's like your brain is like but
don't
yeah yeah yeah i think it's just the way
i was raised i guess
yeah yeah you know so some things
sometimes you've realized
man the way you were how you're raised
as a kid is pretty [ __ ] important
too oh yeah because it it like affects
how you're
how you're like how you subconsciously
think so like yeah
the rest of your life and it takes so
much more effort to unlearn something
yeah it's been a long time to like
relearn she's like learn something for
the first time did you ever like catch
yourself doing something that your
parents
used to do to you when you were a kid
like the way they would talk or like oh
yeah
i remember like oh i think what was it
like
my dad used to have this really specific
way of making excuses up and i caught
myself doing it one time and i was like
[ __ ] yeah i picked it up it's that
moment where you're like [ __ ] i am my
dad's kid
[ __ ] i'm becoming you i thought i was
superior this whole time
but i was just equal that's the thing
right it's like you listen to your dad
you know what you're doing yeah you
listen to all your life and then when
you get to like your teens
and you hear it you make fun of them for
being like oh look at this board i'm
gonna i'm never gonna be like that i
think years later
oh no i was i was the same this entire
time
yeah it's been a lot of like always has
been i've had to like physically like
mentally just be like don't do this
don't do this don't do this thing don't
do this thing because
because i thought they were like weird
things nothing bad but like just little
quirks that my parents would do and i'm
like i don't know it's just like certain
ways you say things where you're just
like
this is the first time me saying it but
for some reason i've heard it before
yeah
yeah you're like [ __ ] my parents they
planted the seed
oh my god but yeah i mean anahana i
still love it to this day
mid okay
if that's the case what anime would you
recommend to someone to
make them cry what what what what's the
golden time
what is it golden time is that the right
name yeah yeah
golden time yeah i always [ __ ] call
it something different by accident like
golden week or something
i mean to me golden time is in the same
category as anahana for like
there's a cult though i like the cult
i'm kidding
i i just found that whole cult arc
really dumb and i really enjoyed how
stupid that was i can't even remember i
can't even remember there was like a
part where she was like brainwashed in a
cult or some [ __ ]
that happened i i think so i don't know
again i've i'm
basically an alzheimer's patient in
waiting so i mean i'm probably the wrong
person i did i definitely didn't get a
cry boner though from watching
golden time uh what is another show
that's like
really good cry porn an anime it's the
best cry porn anime
um i i mean anything by shinkai
jin maeda right yeah anything my mind
are doing anything by shinko i'm not one
of those people who knows okay um
anything by key studios basically yeah
it's like pretty good
i didn't find angel beats as sad as
everyone else because i felt like
it was obvious it was going to happen
though yeah i i i felt exactly the same
where i really
it was my same problem with clan ad just
less stretched out
where it was so obviously trying to make
you cry
it was yeah it's it's literally just cry
porn where you just
it was going to cry it was designs just
to like make you cry and make you shed
tears yeah but i have like an initial
like my cry boner's rock hard the moment
i see maya june you know what i mean
it's like i know
it's like i don't even have to watch it
and i'm i'm already prepared
so i just googled saddest anime okay
just just
saddest anime and google what says
number one
and then emily even google agrees uh
plastic memories
which is it was just
it was you knew okay again it was it was
just basically
cancer with waifu's basically yeah
that's what it was
that's that's it's like that i want to
eat your pancreas that's right
i want to eat pancreas [ __ ] i
[Music]
okay there's there's a difference
between sad and bleak
yeah i feel like madoka magic is more on
the bleak side so yeah medical magic
goes like grief crying
there's this guilty crown here guilty
crowd
why i cried because of how bad the
ending was if that's what they mean by
that
stein's actually you know what i really
like guilty crown i'm gonna say it
i like it no one though i like all the
grilled cram really yeah
you know what connor i'm absolutely
there with you yes
it's the one [ __ ] time me and conor
agree people need to stop comparing it
to
as a shitty code kiosk kokios is in its
its own work
i don't compare it to code gas but i
still thought the ending was yeah
it wasn't it was me it wasn't the best
ending in the world but man it was a
[ __ ] good writer
entertaining as crying i think i
probably did
i was i was actually this close to
crying and that's
it wasn't because of the story it was
just because of how good it is
here's the thing the thing the thing
about me and crying is that music has
so much more power over here than it
does yeah
that's if if there's a good soundtrack
um i i'm i
i'm like almost always why do you think
i cried to everything mighty jun does
yeah it's because he makes the music as
well which makes me cry like a [ __ ]
but like i don't know like i i liked
like guilty crown had its
like emotional moments and obviously you
know the soundtrack was good but like
i don't know my my my cry burn was like
a half job the entire time i was like i
really liked it
it's like it was so close maybe maybe
it's because i haven't watched it in
like
four or five years but i maybe it's rose
tinted glasses i'm looking zero now yeah
i remember i really [ __ ] enjoyed it i
i really enjoyed it not in the sense
where
hey i'm gonna recommend this as a good
show i'm gonna i really enjoyed it in
this in the sense where
it was just here's a lot of dumb anime
tropes that i enjoy
i'm not gonna i don't care if they make
any sense whether they put these anime
tropes in
but it's just it's just like a lot of
good popcorn fun yeah yeah yeah
it was what are you oh it's a great show
yeah it's it's kind it kind of reminds
me i
remember when darling in the franxx
first aired i called darling in the
franks the guilty crown of this
generation
and i kind of still agree with myself on
that point where darling the friends got
stupid as [ __ ]
yeah but it was entertainingly stupid of
course
yeah i mean the the thing about darling
in france is that i went through a whole
[ __ ] emotional arc with it
because it was the first half i would
say was actually legitimately good did
you watch it weekly by the way
yeah i did watch it weekly so i really
thought that darling the franks
was a great character drama with mex in
it and i was
super super emotionally invested in the
in this as a series
and then the [ __ ] space thing happens
and then it went my trigger was like let
me introduce myself
yeah exactly and my enjoyment for
darling the franks kind of just
shifted after that i didn't i wasn't
emotionally
attached anymore it wasn't that same
kind of enjoyment it was just the
look at all this [ __ ] happening instead
of enjoyment